all right Jennifer Garner you me a wall
thank you have a look at you peppermint
yes so good so this is the first time in
11 years that you're getting into action
yeah it's a long time you know I had
done so much of it and had really oddly
that was kind of what I was known for
yeah and then I had babies and I was
either pregnant or nursing or recovering
from one of those things and it just
didn't feel like the right time also
action just takes so much time and
intensive geno training and preparation
that I really it wasn't until my kids
were back at all three kids were in
school that I could devote that kind of
time to it yeah and what was it like
preparing for the role physically after
eleven years it was very intense
I was in good shape going into preparing
for the role but the difference between
being in good shape and being an action
shape it's a very very different ball of
wax so um yeah I just put my head down I
knew what I needed to do I said to them
I know how to train for this I know what
I need to do if you'll just let me do it
and I I've worked with Simone de LaRue
body by Simone and she and I just we
killed it every single day oh my good
pretty hardcore yeah and you do really
well in the movie I mean you're amazing
so you have three beautiful kids I know
the movie is rated R but who do you
think out of your three kids would like
to see mom kick butt them Oh none of my
kids would not to see this movie they
are too little it is a fantasy film it
is not for them but I think that when
they're older I don't know I don't know
maybe my middle one would be the one
most likely to UM although none of my
they don't like to see me in movies
really they just want me to be mom
really they don't want to so they don't
watch your movies um not very much Oh
interesting why do you think that is I
think they want me to be their mom and
that's it yeah for nobody else yeah I
love that so we're ranking revenge
characters so there's three so who would
you say is the most badass so we have
Liam Neeson and
uma Thurman in Kill Bill and then we
have canneries in John wick ooh uh Liam
Neeson that father rage I mean Kill Bill
is such a just because it's uma Thurman
I'm gonna have to go Kill Bill it's all
about the girl girl power
you want to see the girl the girl power
you know you're just taken over and
you're such a huge celebrity but you're
also so likeable and humble and I know a
lot of the times you say that your
Southern roots is what you know bring
your values so how do you maintain your
values in Hollywood circus um you don't
live in the Hollywood circuit live in
your house yes I mean you live in your
house and you you choose the people that
you're gonna hang out with and and I by
the way find most actors that I'm
friends with to have very similar values
I don't think people are as crazy as
maybe they seem from the outside awesome
thank you thank you